en 2010 est ce qu'on va surveiller de
très près au moyen orient c'est d'abord
la suite de la lutte contre le groupe
armé islamique en irak où on est
toujours en train de mener une opération
militaire majeure pour reprendre la
ville de mossoul dans le nord du pays
on peut penser que d'ici quelques mois
cette opération aura permis de reprendre
le contrôle de ce territoire pour le
gouvernement irakien ce sera une période
cruciale dangereuses jusqu'à un certain
point
que va-t-il arriver de tous ces groupes
qui participe en ce moment à l'offensive
qui ont un intérêt commun les milices
chiites les sunnites les forces kurdes
comment une fois le territoire conquis
vont se comporter ces groupes qui sont
un peu sortis de leur zone d'influencé
traditionnelle qui sont maintenant très
très armés va-t-on assister à des
déchirements à des conflits à une
recrudescence de la violence entre ces
groupes qui avaient déjà des problèmes à
cohabiter avant l'arrivée du groupe armé
état islamique
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une tentative
les milices chiites par exemple des
sunnites et des membres de la communauté
kurde de redessiner la carte de l'irak
on va aussi surveiller bien sûr ce qui
se passe du côté de la syrie la syrie
sur laquelle on avait tous les yeux
rivés à la fin 2016 avec la reprise
d'alep par le régime syrien de bachar
al-assad appuyé par les russes et par
l'iran maintenant la ville d'alep et
reprise ce n'est pas la fin de la guerre
ce que l'on constate c'est la naissance
d'une nouvelle collaboration entre la
turquie et la russie une collaboration
qui étonne parce que depuis le tout
début du conflit ces deux pays ont des
objectifs annoncés affiché
diamétralement opposées la turquie et le
président erdan qui souhaite d'abord et
avant tout le départ de bachar al assad
alors que la russie de vladimir poutine
soutient le régime lui a permis cette
victoire importante à la fin décembre la
reprise
dallest qu'est ce que va donner cette
nouvelle alliance sur le terrain ça a
permis cette trêve
maintenant on veut pouvoir relancer le
processus de négociation paie mais ce
qui est important de noter c'est que ces
négociations n'auront pas lieu à genève
comme ç'a été le cas par le passé mais
astana kazakhstan
ce que l'on constate aussi c'est que
l'occident les etats-unis les nations
unies sont complètement évacué de tous
ces pourparlers cette tentative
diplomatique d'enfin résoudre cette
crise
[Musique]